[Musique]
le gouvernement à la france un sourire
ils veulent pas réformer les retraites
ils veulent gagner la petite taille des
opinions nous on veut réformer les
retraites nous nous avons nous sommes
pas rentrer dans ce jeu nous avons
présenté un contre-projet qui est
structuré avec un financement pour les
retraites
moi ce que je mesure est ce qui fait
réagir aujourd'hui le parlement et
toutes les oppositions
c'est ce mépris du parlement de
président de la république et ce
gouvernement qui ont méprisé les corps
intermédiaires qui ont méprisé les les
élus locaux qui ont méprisé les français
avec des phrases assassines du président
de la république lorsqu'il parle de ceux
qui ne sont rien et c'est là c'est la
même chose pour le parlement audio aux
députés voter le texte voté cette
réforme
et puis surtout vous l'a voté vite parce
qu'on a autre chose à faire que de
perdre du temps avec vous et puis le
financement soit n'occupera plus tard
parce que c'est pas de votre niveau
on verra ça dans deux mois le drame de
notre pays c'est que le parlement ne
servent plus à rien le drame de notre
démocratie aujourd'hui c'est que le
l'exécutif le gouvernement a oublié
qu'il y avait 577 députés qui
représentait le peuple qui représentait
le peuple français et qui avaient le
devoir de s'exprimer
on nous a court circuité sur ce sujet on
voit bien que l'assemblée nationale ne
peut pas faire son travail
on veut nous faire légiférer hausse et
au sénat en quelques semaines seulement
la place du président macro c'est un
moment de honte est vite passé je
retirerais ce texte la très très vite et
puis je remettrai tout le monde autour
de la table pour faire quelque chose de
sage de sérieux d'équilibré aujourd'hui
les détails on les connaît pas parce que
le gouvernement il les découvre encore
saint-ex mal préparé le gouvernement
découvre son première sur des couches
bien sûr en fait ce texte il souffre
d'une faute originelle
on n'a pas voulu parler de l'âge est ce
que je constate depuis trois ans et que
le handicap n'est pas une véritable
ambition pour ce gouvernement il y a
encore aujourd'hui en france quinze
mille enfants en situation de handicap
qui n'ont pas de solution qui ne peuvent
pas aller à l'école sur ce sujet comme
sur beaucoup d'autres on y frapper de ce
syndrome du crocodile et emmanuel macron
notamment on a une grande bouche on a
des petits bras le handicap il n'a pas
de couleur politique
c'est un sujet trop important et trop
grave pour uniquement faire des effets
d'annoncé des effets de manche
chez les républicains on ne naît pas là
dessus nous ce qu'on veut c'est un
mouvement de fond
[Musique]